bei uns im studio ist jetzt bild tvb
chef claus strunz klaus wie ist deine
meinung zu dem thema findet das eine
sinnvolle maßnahme nein es ist natürlich
falsch falsch falsch ich sage es bewusst
dreimal damit es auch jeder hört
diese idee ungeimpfte aus dem saal zu
verbannen auf der tribüne zur schau zu
stellen guck mal da oben sitzen die
ungeimpften
das gehört nicht in dieses parlament und
ich empfinde die sind zwei klassen
bundestag seit heute als schande
wir haben den bundestag uns auch
angeguckt den großen plenarsaal es ist
ja eigentlich genügend platz genügend
abstand möglichkeiten die man da ein
einhalten können also es gab ja auch
vorher schon der regel unter wolfgang
schäuble dem parlamentspräsidenten das
war 3g 3g kennen viele wir alle auch wir
hier vom arbeitsplatz und 3g ist die
richtige lösung auch für das parlament
dann auch das parlament dessen
arbeitsplatz also das bedeutet man es
geimpft genesen oder legt einen test vor
ich weiß ja nicht wie es euch geht aber
ich fühle mich ehrlich gesagt immer noch
am sichersten in einer umgebung von
getesteten menschen wir alle hier im
studio sind getestet sonst werden wir
nicht im studio ob ihr geimpft seid geht
mich eigentlich gar nichts an und so
muss auch das parlament funktionieren
und nicht mit einer art
diskriminierungskampagne ungeimpften
gegenüber ich überlege mir auch was ist
die symbolik also wer muss denn
eigentlich immer irgendwo anders hin ins
eck muss der der etwas angestellt hat
war glaube ich nur noch früher so auf
die strafbank muss man beim eishockey
war ein foul spielt also es gibt
überhaupt keine positive legitimation
und was mich im prinzip am meisten
aufregt ist ja eigentlich finde ich
sogar ganz schön weil es offen legt die
unglaubwürdigkeit dieser entscheidung
als hauptargument nennen die
parlamentarier nämlich man wolle die
ungeimpften schützen deshalb tue man sie
raus aus diesem gefährlichen saal wo ja
geimpfte und gebürstete menschen setzen
um sie selber vor einer ansteckung zu
schützen das ist in einem raum wir haben
ihn ja vorhin angeguckt wie dem dem
bundestag den plenarsaal natürlich an
absurdität nicht zu übertreffen denn
dieser plenarsaal ist quasi open air mit
ich weiß nicht 100 meter hohen decken
und einem riesigen platzangebot das
bedeutet die mitgelieferte deutung
dieser entscheidung lautet man muss
geimpfte vor den ungeimpften schützen
und dann sind wir sehr sehr schnell bei
hier unten sind die guten da oben sind
die bösen hier unten sind die
vernünftigen da oben sind die
unvernünftigen da unten sind die
verantwortungsvollen da oben sind die
nicht verantwortungsvollen da unten sind
die gesunden da oben sind die
aussätzigen und das ist etwas was nicht
in dieses parlament gehört und ich
vermisse den aufschrei zb der liberalen
warum wird denn dieses große thema der
freiheit jetzt wieder da fdp überlassen
die das heute wahrscheinlich zu einem
großen schauspiel nutzen wird aus meiner
sicht zu recht mit gutem recht weil es
eine absurde entscheidung ist wo ist
denn der große liberalen führer
christian lindner jetzt und sagt leute
jetzt ist eine grenze überschritten
das geht nicht in meinem in unserem in
unser aller parlament das ist nicht
zulässig hier ist die grenze übrigen und
es ist jetzt das parlament das wäre
vielleicht weniger wäre es das einzig
positive das man jetzt im parlament
sehen kann wie dieses ganze land
offensichtlich geordnet werden soll in
die guten die geimpft sind und die bösen
schlimmen andere gefährdet die ungeimpft
sind das ertrage ich nur schwer und ich
hoffe dass darüber diskutiert wird ich
hoffe sogar dass es klagen gibt und dann
bin ich mal gespannt ob die justiz zu
einem anderen urteil kommt das was dann
entschieden wird würde ich als
staatsbürger sozusagen zur kenntnis
nehmen aber wenn da rauskommt das ist
okay kriege ich noch mehr zweifel
wahrscheinlich würde ja heute im
bundestag sogar darüber diskutiert
werden 13 uhr wie gesagt die fragestunde
die erste mit bundeskanzler olaf scholz
hier live auch bei bild da wird
interessant sein zu beobachten wie die
afg sich dann verhält ob die sozusagen
geschlossen auf die tribüne geht in dem
fall vielleicht sogar um die geimpften
nicht so aus aber allein ich finde diese
vokabel also im bundestag kann man sich
jetzt so verhalten dass man menschen
outet indem man wenn man geimpft ist
unten sitzen bleibt und nur die
ungeimpften und man muss also quasi um
eine diskriminierung zu vermeiden
irgendwie sachen machen ich meine wo
sind wir denn jetzt angekommen dieser
pandemie ich glaube inzwischen dass die
größte folge der pandemie nicht etwa
gesundheitlich und medizinische themen
sind sondern die größte folge der
pandemie ist dass wir uns bewusst machen
müssen was es zu verteidigen gilt in
unsere demokratie nämlich die freiheit
die freiheit im parlament ich nochmal da
kommen gesunde parlamentarier die haben
nicht corona sie zeigen einen test vor
dass sie sozusagen negativ sind und
dürfen nicht in den plenarsaal was kommt
denn da als nächstes der alcotest unter
der wissen die wesensprüfung oder die
gewissensprüfung also irgendwo es hier
jetzt sozusagen wirklich ein punkt
erreicht ein ad wendepunkt und an diesem
beispiel und das meine ich das ist ja
vielleicht sozusagen für zyniker noch
das einzig gute daran dass man im
parlament jetzt sehen kann was in den
köpfen von politikern vor geht die diese
ausgrenzungspolitik verfolgen und
hoffentlich ist die debatte die wir
heute auch zeigen werden dort wird die
wie soll ich sagen steil und mit aller
mit aller kraft geführt und hoffentlich
wird sie auch mit einem liberalen
momentum geführt und nicht nur von den
seiten befeuert nun hat für die
brandopfer hin gesagt warum sollen für
volksvertreter andere regeln gelten als
für das volk also ins restaurant komme
ich auch nur mit zwei gehe ja aber das
argument lautet wenn man das parlament
in seiner ich habe da vielleicht also
ich habe eine riesen hochachtung vor dem
parlament für mich das parlament
sozusagen der wichtigste platz der
demokratie und wenn man den diesen
diesen außergewöhnlichen platz zu
vergleichen versucht mit etwas anderem
dann ist es der arbeitsplatz und nicht
die kneipe und deshalb muss gelten was
auch an den meisten arbeitsplätzen geld
nämlich 3g s hat auch gegolten bis diese
neue parlamentspräsidentin von der spd
sozusagen ans ruder kam jetzt gibt es
plötzlich die verschärften regelungen
und da wird mir doch angst und bange bei
der arbeit wenn ich darüber nachdenke
was dieses symbol für die korona politik
dieser spd geführten regierung in der
zukunft bedeuten kann nämlich dass wir
nicht zueinander finden sondern weit
auseinanderdriften und die tribünen weil
man es ja wir haben uns angeschaut sind
ja auch relativ klein im vergleich zu
den großen plenarsaal wie viel platz ist
da unten gibt würde auch bedeuten dass
die ungeimpften auf dieser kleinen
tribüne dann alle platz
wer schon mal spannend sein wie für
ungeimpfte gibt es da überhaupt und eins
ist ja auch je mehr ich darüber
nachdenke desto mehr rege ich mich auch
auf denn denken wir noch mal einen
aspekt durch jemand kann sich nicht
impfen lassen wegen einer
gesundheitlichen disposition der wird
jetzt der auch da hoch verband oder er
muss offenlegen wahrscheinlich also wer
hat man dann so eine armbinde rom wo
draufsteht ich habe hohen blutdruck und
deshalb lasst mich bitte hier rein ich
meine das sind das sind doch zustände
wenn wir über die vor zwei jahren
geredet hätten und ich hätte gesagt so
wird es kommen dann hättet ihr zu mir
gesagt was man auflegt ich wieder hin
ändert seine medikamente du bist
verrückt geworden wir sind in einer
verrückten zeit im besten sinne des
wortes verrückt aus dem bild gewandert
verrutscht und das muss sich sehr sehr
sehr sehr schnell ändern weil es sonst
nämlich folgeschäden longo bit ist dann
eine einen folgeschaden für die
demokratie nicht für den menschlichen
körper davor habe ich wirklich
angst wir sehen hier die fraktionen der
afg wie kriegt man das hin in dieser
diskussion klaus dass man für die sache
antritt so wie du es gerade tue es aber
gleichzeitig nicht in den ruch kommt
anhänger der afg zu sagen jetzt achtung
jetzt wird philosophisch da halte ich es
mit habermas großer philosoph großer
denker der hat mir gesagt das wichtigste
ist in einer debatte der zwanglose zwang
des besseren arguments
also das bedeutet übersetzt wenn ein
argument in sich für die mehrheit der
menschen absolut überzeugend ist dann
hat es auch die kraft die mehrheit zu
überzeugen alles was gekünstelt pr ich
mein mann mein hintern auf meinem
parlaments stuhl mein amt retten wo man
spürt das ist ein argument deshalb nicht
den zwanglosen zwang sondern das ist
gekünstelt für einen zweck dem glauben
die menschen nicht also setzen wir auf
den zwanglosen zwang des stärkeren
argument wenn jemand sagt wenn du ins
wasser springt wirst du nass dann kann
man dagegen reden wie man will man wird
verlieren weil man erhalten hast und das
finde ich für mich in dieser debatte
dass die argumente nicht so überzeugend
vorgetragen werden wie sie vorgetragen
gehören damit einem mehrheit sie hört
aufnimmt durchdenkt und ihn dann aus
freien stücken folgt das ist eigentlich
eine demokratie in der ich leben müsste
inzwischen leben wenn der demokratie wo
ungeimpfte verband und diskriminiert
werden unangenehm